well you'll have to forgive the cliche
but the wheels of justice turn very
slowly and this has been a long time
coming the main tv news broadcasters
began a campaign more than a decade ago
for cameras to be allowed into criminal
courts
in 2009
cameras were allowed into the supreme
court and four years later there were
cameras installed in the court of appeal
but the tv news broadcasters argued that
the public had a right to see what went
on in criminal cases
the argument was for more openness but
also for the public's better
understanding
of what was being done after all inside
public buildings um so now the same for
crown courts where the most serious
criminal cases are heard
but and there's a very big but there's
going to be very limited access and
viewers
will see only a very small part of
proceedings all they'll see is the judge
see and hear the judge passing sentence
and giving the explanation
for that particular punishment so no
real context unless the judge decides to
give a lot of detail into
the reasoning behind the sentence being
imposed